if you give them the freedoms humans
will always dazzle you that much I know
that's if you can hack it to an AI and
make it do bad things you know how do we
make sure that that's not possible I
mean both as an astronomer and an
astronaut to put my two hands on the
greatest telescope in the world up in
space I mean what a what a thrill I
would wonder why do I still feel unhappy
in the face of achievement and success
and so they learn about each other's
roles and build trust among each other
so it's very easy to focus on the
technology thank you Alex were connected
to the anti-war movement in Vietnam they
were connected to people that were
involved in the environmental if you
don't study what's going on a
marketplace you're gonna be led by
somebody else who does so what's my
feedback to you how do you handle it
what we're gonna be I think that the two
big questions for Humanity are what is
the trajectory of intelligence and
sentience in other words like what's the
point
and also like how do we get there
without killing each other or just just
all dying violently in other words this
molecule was dictating what had to be
done more ancient more powerful deeper
forces are at work that have been
shaping us for goodness for a much
longer time all it knows is that it's
received these different patterns that
it can correlate them with other
patterns and that's how it puts together
your perception of the world it just
came out you know I wrote the melody and
the lyrics and it just something fits or
it doesn't many stories you know make
sure they're real see how the mainstream
media reported on them see if the
mainstream media reported on them try to
ascertain like where they got this stuff
from is the Happiness equation now there
is one common thing across every moment
in your life you've ever felt that are
we satisfied
the goals of our best selves to
basically lift everybody up I have the
OpenCog system whose knowledge
representation is a network a weighted
labeled hyper graph and there's multiple
AI algorithms acting on this common
knowledge graph my viewpoint is that God
or source cannot exist without creation
existing because it emerges through
creation love of self so dying and not
being automatically replaced by the
division of other facts because I
psychiatric patient there's no one place
in the head you can point to but if we
see overlapping symptom ology we can
know that that part of the brain is
involved what I discovered after just
one year of teaching by the system that
they told me to do to use was that no
one was learning and also if you think
you ask yourself why is it that the
sound of AA
subject they feels very different from
say that experience of the color red but
so if we could extend the youthfulness
of the body this regenerative properties
that you see this is a giant automation
story and so we have to start owning the
problem and then have real solutions
that are going to be massive
that's the generational challenge but
that's why I'm running for president
they're driven in large part by
temperamental differences so that would
be in the big five extraversion
neuroticism agreeableness
conscientiousness and openness
[Music]